uh of course matt gourley also with us
good to see you matt
hi guys you were having some issue it
took us a while to connect with you
because
you're having some issue at your house
what's going on at your house well maybe
you can hear some ambient noise like uh
birds chirping and dogs barking because
all my windows in my office are open
because
something died in the walls of our house
and it's a problem that when you have it
you can't really do anything about it
but just wait it out unless you want to
rip your walls apart well wait a minute
hold on let's back this up just a little
bit
what do you think died in your wall oh
my cousin
who was last seen saying your cousin
whose last last time you talked to him
which was six weeks ago was i'm gonna go
look inside your wall
i'm not feeling great some heart
palpitations but still i'm gonna go look
inside your wall and then you haven't
seen him since
and now you smell something died in the
wall yeah it is awful here i hope it's
only
a mouse or a rat i hope it's not
something bigger like a
god forbid like a raccoon or something
is that because let me understand is
that because you think a raccoon has
more of a
enlightened spirit than a mouse or
you're telling you just about the size
and the cuter but yeah the size because
oh you're only worried about the size so
yeah yeah okay all right less decay time
so you don't get as sad when like a
a skinny guy dies but when a fat guy
tries to really bum
out wow so you let the smell out and
then the carcass just stays
in your walls you have to let it dry out
and basically mummify
or else it's ripped the walls apart i
don't know what else to do well excuse
me do they have any way
of detecting you think in this modern
era there'd be some kind of device
you know the way that does that thing
you can buy literally for six dollars at
the hardware store that helps you find
where the stud is
stud finder yeah my wife had a good stud
finder
come on no no she was finding where the
stud was in the wall i wasn't talking
about
yeah okay no no i why did why what made
you think i was talking about anything
else anyway my wife
it's just pretty clear when she met me
she found her stud right
because i was holding a stud finder that
i got at the hardware store
i don't know why this is confusing but
isn't there some kind of device
matt that would tell you the source of
these noxious gases
not that i'm aware of i even like
brought my cat into the office to see if
she would kind of just smell in a
certain spot but she couldn't care less
it doesn't even seem to notice it it's
horrible well cats are
uh dispensed death all the time we have
cats and all they do is
you know kill things and try and bring
it into the house
and uh it's i mean large dogs and it's
terrible
no they just like birds and what it's
just it's or if they find something
that's dead they bring it into the house
yeah so why would they care about the
smell well i would think she would just
because our cat is food obsessed she's
just single-minded i'm telling you more
than
anything i've ever seen in any creature
on earth before
she's obsessed she will eat a full bowl
of food
that's the size of a basketball and
won't stop until she vomits have you
ever found
uh your cat ordering stuff on grubhub
like a car pulls up and they're like is
there a is there a mr chips uh here
what's your cat what's your cat's name
it's margo yeah she has
learned to open our cabinet trash like
you know the kind that are flush with
the kitchen cabinets she can
open it i swear she's evolving thumbs we
had to put a child proof lock on her
goddamn cabinets
because of his cat our dog we have two
golden retrievers and the younger one
loki has figured out how to order
pornography
what kind of pornography is loki into
it's all shih tzu very soft core
and apparently loki wants there to be
some story
so a plot driven
what's it plot driven porn and film not
video oh no no hates video hates video
and hates
there's got to be a decent story there
and so
i've sometimes even watched uh there
have been times where
we loki speeds through the sex you know
like his paw just goes and hits the fast
forward and we speed through it
just because it's the because the plot
is more what
loki's into so um i mean sometimes we
watch the sex
if it's just well i said well you know i
can't let the dog watch tv alone
you know so i cause god knows you know
what if
what if uh pay-per-view and the next
thing you know we owe a lot of money so
no i have to be there with loki when we
watch the softcore pornography
is it dog porn or oh god no no who wants
to watch dogs do it
okay no and dogs i mean they have no
there's no erotic thrill for
any a dog will hump a desk a dog will
hump a fire hydrant a dog will hump
anything so
that would be the level of their porn no
he likes bo loki likes bodice rippers
you know
like uh anything that's he likes
costumes he likes to be a plot
yeah uh and so yeah it's uh and then i
i watch with him but it's they're good
stories they tell really good stories we
watch red shoe diaries some of the old
showtime stuff
god what the [ __ ] it's true but only the
one dog the other dog is not into this
oh my god oh no no bosco
who's the older one hates pornography
yeah just hates pornography
absolutely hates it loves musicals the
mgm musicals they're really good ones
loves uh singing in the rain just all
those great mgm musicals
but um so we don't watch tv together we
watch have to have to watch it
separately
okay we have such a good show to get to
today and listen
another quick thing if your dog is
hooked on porn uh you can contact this
toll-free number that will not be at the
uh end of this podcast it won't exist
because i'm
that's not doesn't exist but anyway if
your dog has a real problem with uh
pornography
uh you can get help if you listen for
the number that doesn't exist it's at
the end of this podcast